because today's show is dedicated to
decluttering everything in our
lives and as you can see i'm in the
kitchen
and who better to join us with some hot
tips and the hot recipe
is the one and only the hottest rachel
ray
hi sweetheart do you have your mug
rachel this is the greatest gift i have
ever gotten
so rich cervini is like rachel and i's
like he's like our dad he's like a
godfather he's like
the head of our show and he he is just
amazing and so this is to you rich
cervini cheers rachel this is the
greatest
most incredible gift ever thank you
you're welcome my darling i love that
you're doing decluttering
uh it is such an important concept and
congratulations to our newlyweds and
happy birthday to the bride
i know don and i never build anything
together
that would that would ignite a war of
epic proportions
we have one hammer we are terrible
diyers
so that's not happening yet and
yeah no one in the kitchen is like you
so what are we making today
today i know you wanted to learn a uh
a quick soup this is a soup that you can
make in one
skillet one deep skillet and it will use
up a lot of staples that are already on
hand
in many of our pantries and things that
we have on hand in our fridge
the one thing you're gonna have to
purchase for this dish probably
um is uh dark leafy greens are dark
leafy greens of some sort we're using
escarole today
we're going to make beans and greens and
pasta soup
in one pan very simple i love you
a little bit we have two pots because we
want the the
stock to already be at a boil when we
add it but literally everyone can make
this in one pot
and you can make it vegetarian you can
adapt it to be vegetarian
but you're going to get protein great
nutrition from the dark greens
it's going to be fun for everybody to
eat because of the pasta we're going to
top it with cheese as well
so let's get this going and we can talk
more about decluttering pantry because
it's such an important thing for folks
especially
right now right yes so
in the pan if you're using meat i
am using pancetta roll cured meat
similar to bacon but it
is not smoked and i've diced it
fairly small and it's cooking out or
rendering in a little olive oil
two turns of the pan of olive oil is
what we used
and a great tip anytime we're using
pancetta
this is a nice meaty piece of pancetta
is to put it in the freezer for a couple
of minutes
uh to firm it up so that it's more solid
when you're putting your knife through
it
right same any protein you're trying to
slice a steak a piece of chicken for a
stir-fry
any protein put it in the freezer and
your knife will go through it a lot
quicker and easier
by the way i've never heard that before
that's a really cool tip freeze your
meat freeze your protein and you'll be
able to cut it better
okay already checkity check first
check any check check now we're going to
use our bench scrape
or any any facsimile thereof and we're
going to add onions and garlic to our
pancetta
and our olive oil again if we are making
this vegetarian
all we have to do is omit the pancetta
it will still be delicious
so onions one onion or two small onions
finely chopped and two cloves of garlic
grated or chopped arthur can you smell
this
arthur's our resident kitchen cat he
meows
okay a little uh black pepper or red
pepper
now black pepper is fine and if you want
to use red pepper my family
loves red pepper my mom's a little
sicilian lady
you can use flake which everyone has
or this stuff this is calabrian chili
paste
i have it over here in the jar i can
show you i love
the taste of this you really turned me
on to this the last time
we cooked together on your show you are
now synonymous with calabrian chili
paste and it really does
add such a unique flavor and you know
remember you can mix that just with
honey and drizzle it on cheese
it'll blow your mind and you know what
else the hot honey is good for the
calabrian chili paste and honey
pizza but on pizza yes like the bee
sting
by roberta's pizza and i also love a
blue cheese
with honey i think that's a fantastic
combination as well
oh good okay so we've got our
some source of spice our onions the
pancetta if you're using it and the
garlic
now we literally just add
everything to the pan in stages and let
it cook out
and that's it dinner's done in less than
20 minutes
so we're going to open our creams
escarole
spinach kale any of that so this is
probably the the one
fresh thing you would have to buy for
this dish and anytime we use
dark greens a great tip is to add a
little bit of nutmeg
it highlights the flavor of dark greens
and anything with dairy anything with a
lot of uh
cream or creme fraiche um
or mascarpone cheese or ricotta you add
a little
of the nutmeg as well
magic with dark greens okay so
okay i have some right here what i love
about this recipe
is that so many of us have these things
on hand we all have onions
garlic these are white beans just from a
can
cannellini beans a can of cannellini a
can of candy which you'll have in the
pantry that's right
and rachel we're gonna go to a quick
commercial break so i'm gonna
like we're gonna do our beans and then
as soon as we come back we are going to
go god do i put the beans in wait
okay put your breads are stuck in the
pot
with your pasta and your beans or it
won't be cooked at the end of the show
okay where do i put the pasta in the
beans everything goes into the one pan
the pasta the beans
okay okay and beans perfect okay i
didn't mess up i
i almost messed up but it wasn't as bad
as i thought
[Laughter]
pour it all in there and we'll be right
back as drew said
okay perfect okay i've got this all
working now do i put the broth in before
we go to break two everything
everything okay look the whole
shenanigan
honey show them let's hear it
together and now all we have to do is
let it cook we'll tell everybody our
secret ingredient after your break
okay thank you rachel and you should see
the mess i'm making it's
hilarious we're in the middle of our
decl
clutter power hour i'm here with rachel
ray and we're finishing up her beautiful
beautiful soup that looks so amazing i
cannot
wait rachel how does this look over here
let me see it looks perfect beans greens
and macaroni
you know i don't have a uh a cooked out
one drew i'm adding my secret ingredient
to ours look
is a piece of parmigiano rind always buy
cheese with the rind because it makes
the whole soup taste
like oh so you just throw it right in
you throw it right in and it makes all
of your broth tastes like cheese
and the big finish a little squirt of
lemon juice to almost
cameron diaz loves to squeeze lemon on
all of her food when it's done cooking
in
all things now rachel with cheese you
are
literally starting or you're in your
15th season
in fact we have a clip of you um when
michelle
obama came on your show um which is just
so
amazing and how do you
feel like i am such a spring chicken
here
and you are this incredible vet who has
had
so many your roster of guests rachel
is one of the most impressive things
i've ever seen
does it make you so proud
uh i i i just feel grateful really
it's it's not a really a pride thing for
me it's that
you have the opportunity to to have
conversations with
everyone and some uh michelle obama have
known since before she was the first
lady
and we of course worked together uh on
uh children's initiatives and the
lessons
right and improving school food uh her
entire
uh time is as first lady
uh but you know what i love about um our
show
and and and the show that that you're
new to in developing there
is when you can have on stories of of
real people and that you can just share
the lives of your viewers
with a larger community where people can
look to their neighbors and people that
sound and look like them to be uh their
inspiration
those shows mean as much to me seriously
as as talking to a first lady or
big stars like drew barrymore who was
recently on our television show
which meant the world to me to be on
your show because i felt like i was
joining a roster of such
elevated people and your show is that
your magazine
your show your cookbooks you are such a
hero to me
like i am so excited to be in your world
i am like
a little happy bug in the rachel ray
worlds i am thrilled to be uh
now in your world and now i can be a
return guest by the way i plated and
bowled your pasta
soup your three your bean and macaroni
soup
um because i got so into the declutter
it is
it's so pretty oh give me the beauty
shop beauty shot
here we go i'm not kidding rachel i love
this soup
and i'm gonna go home and i'm gonna take
video of everything you just said
and apply it to my life and show you and
see
what you think thank you rachel so much
and the mob mr beanie's anger